the obr forecast the economy will
contract
this year by 11.3
the largest fall in output for more than
300 years
as the restrictions are eased they
expect the economy to start recovering
growing by five and a half percent next
year 6.6
in 2022 then 2.3
1.7 and 1.8 in the following years
even with growth returning our economic
output
is not expected to return to pre-crisis
levels
until the fourth quarter of 2022
and the economic damage is likely to be
lasting
long-term scarring means in 2025
the economy will be around three percent
smaller
than expected in the march budget
mr speaker the economic impact of
coronavirus and the action we've taken
in response
means that there has been a significant
but necessary
increase in our borrowing and debt
the uk is forecast to borrow a total
of 394 billion pounds
this year equivalent to 19
of gdp the highest recorded level of
borrowing
in our peacetime history
there was more bad news on the jobs
front with the office for budget
responsibility predicting that
unemployment will reach 7.5 percent next
year
and there'll be a pay rise though for
nhs workers
the chancellor said uh there will be a
pay freeze however for other public
sector workers
apart from those that earn less than the
median salary of 24
000 pounds a year national living wage
will increase by 2.2 percent to 8.8
pounds and 91 pence an hour for the over
23s
and also that increase in the minimum
wage
for those under that as well there will
be
a 2.9 billion pound restart program to
help those
who lost their jobs as a result of the
pandemic
to find work in such a difficult context
for the private sector
especially for those people working in
sectors like
retail hospitality and leisure i cannot
justify
a significant across-the-board pay
increase
for all public sector workers instead
we are targeting our resources at those
who need it most to protect public
sector jobs at this time of crisis
and ensure fairness between the public
and private sectors
i'm taking three steps today
first taking account of the pay review
body's advice
we will provide a pay rise to over a
million
nurses doctors and others working in the
nhs
second to protect jobs
pay rises in the rest of the public
sector
will be paused next year
but third we will protect those
on lower incomes the 2.1 million
public sector workers who earn below the
median wage of 24 000 pounds
will be guaranteed a pay rise of at
least
250 pounds what this means mr speaker
is that while the government is making
the difficult decision to control public
sector pay
the majority of public sector workers
will see their pay increase next year
foreign aid is being reduced save the
children says the government has broken
not only a manifesto commitment uh by
cutting aid
uh it's also broken a promise to the
world's poor breaking britain's
reputation
for leadership on the world stage but
the chancellor said the fiscal situation
left him with no choice during a
domestic
fiscal emergency when we need to
prioritize our limited resources
on jobs and public services
sticking rigidly to spending 0.7 of our
national income on
overseas aid is difficult to justify
to the british people especially
when we're seeing the highest peacetime
levels of borrowing on
record i have listened
with great respect to those who have
argued passionately
to retain this target but at a time
of unprecedented crisis government
must make tough choices
i want to reassure the house that we
will continue
to protect the world's poorest spending
the equivalent
of 0.5 of our national income on
overseas aid in 2021
allocating 10 billion pounds at this
spending review
and our intention is to return
to 0.7 percent when the fiscal situation
allows